nervend wir sind live mit zdf heute live
und freuen uns dass ihr dabei seid es
ist tag 1 152 im russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
außenminister lavrov hat jetzt gesagt
dass russland die den ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky und seine regierung
stürzen will außerdem spricht er von
befreiung und dass das russische und das
ukrainische volk künftig zusammen leben
werden was bedeutet diese verschärfung
im ton warum kommt sie jetzt ist das
eine neue strategie oder ein blatt
darüber wollen wir reden und über die
aktuelle lage in der ukraine ihr könnt
uns gerne eure fragen oder eure
meinungen schicken die poste die am
besten oder schickt sie uns per mail wir
sprechen heute mit dem militärexperten
oberst ag wolfgang richter von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik ist
sonst gleich zugeschaltet und mit
unserem reporter dara hassanzadeh in
unterseiten süden der ukraine hallo
daran
hallo daran bericht ist für das zdf seit
einiger zeit aus der ukraine wir hören
mal ganz kurz rein was der russische
außenminister gesagt hat das vergessen
in kairo
dass russische und das ukrainische volk
werden weiterhin zusammen leben wir
werden dem ukrainischen volk auf jeden
fall helfen das regime loszuwerden das
absolut volksfeindliche und anti
historisch ist
wie kommen solche äußerungen in der
ukraine an
die äußerung dieses kriegsziels hat hier
keine großen wellen geschlagen bei den
menschen und das liegt einfach daran
dass seit kriegsbeginn die ukraine sich
genau mit diesem kriegsziel konfrontiert
sehen auch wenn es jetzt erst ganz klar
und offen formuliert wurde präsident
zielinski selber war immer im visier
russischer
geheimdienstaktivitäten auch
ausländische geheimdienste haben davor
gewarnt dass er das staatsfeind nummer
eins ist dass russland versucht ihn zu
inhaftieren oder schlimmeres so gesehen
war das auch für ihn keine neue
ankündigung man kann aber schon sagen
dass die
dieser dieser bezug zur geschichte dass
das den präsidenten und die ukraine
schon sehr trifft weil das ist ein kampf
den sie sehr lange führen und sie für
und dann wissen auch die ukraine vor
allem dass die regierung das dort großes
propaganda potenzial liegt auf der
russischen seite die geschichte falsch
darzustellen war von den ersten reden
putins schon der fall und dagegen
kämpfen sie an und das hat auch
präsident sinn lenski heute gekonnt hat
du sagst es gerade auf der anderen seite
in diesem krieg sind schon so viele
schlimme worte gefallen aber vielleicht
kannst du noch mal genauer darauf
eingehen warum sich selensky so
angegriffen gefühlt hat von diesem
vorwurf der geschichtslosigkeit
es liegt vor allem darin dass die
russische seite immer behauptet dass
die ukraine gar kein eigenes land sei
keine eigene kulturen kein eigenes volk
sei sie sei teil des russischen volkes
in wirklichkeit ist es genau umgekehrt
die erste hauptstadt ruder der fußball
kf und dann wurde erst moskau entwickelt
und sie hatten halt aufgrund der des
verlaufs der geschichte nun mal kein
eigenes staatsgebiet und wurden
natürlich auch von der sowjetunion als
so wird republik kopiert und integriert
und annektiert und sie haben jetzt erst
seit kurzem den anfang der 90er jahre
ihre unabhängigkeit und deswegen ist
ihnen das auch so wichtig
dazu schreibt das ju auf youtube mich
würde mal interessieren warum überhaupt
noch jemand denen irgendetwas glaubt
dass muss denen doch selbst peinlich
sein
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass die
russische regierung schon länger am
sturz der ukrainischen regierung zu
arbeiten scheint also die ukraine wird
ja nicht nur mit waffen von außen
angegriffen sondern russland greift
diesen ganzen staat ja auch von innen an
wenn wir daran denken dass
geheimdienstmitarbeiter offensichtlich
die seiten gewechselt haben sie längst
sehr zum teil ausgetauscht oder
offensichtlich wurden attentate
verhindert wie es das
ist genauso also zeit der unabhängigkeit
der ukraine wo warst du mit dem
budapester mama rantum anfang der 90er
jahre beschlossen wurde die ukraine gibt
ihre atomwaffen ab und erhält dafür die
unabhängigkeit ab diesem moment haben
russische geheimdienste die ukraine
infiltriert vor allem gerade in den
behörden im mittleren bereich waren
leute auf von beiden seiten bezahlt und
die russische regierung dachte wohl auch
am anfang des krieges dass sie all diese
zelt aktivieren könnte das hat nicht
geklappt weil die ukraine sehr schnell
reagiert hatten da hat vor allem am
anfang des krieges die territorialen
verteidigung so große rolle gespielt es
waren einfach freiwillige die sich allzu
roadblock schichten eingetragen haben es
war ein mietshäuser wo die anwohner
nachtschichten organisiert haben dass
ihr eingang kontrolliert wurde und so
konnten wirklich sehr viele saboteure
und auch agenten am anfang im krieg
festgenommen werden und identifiziert
werden und vor allem konnte ihr
bewegungs kreis auch eingeschränkt
werden das heißt dass das eine sache die
schon seit jahrzehnten läuft und nicht
erst mit beginn des krieges
wer würde schon sagen dass auch
vor denselben problemen sehen sich ja
auch andere länder konfrontiert im wald
die kurven in belarus ist sich
lukaschenko auch nicht seine apparate so
sicher und selbst wir in deutschland
haben ja gespürt dass dort gegen unsere
demokratie gearbeitet wird das
demokratiefeindliche gruppierung von
russland finanziert werden unterstützt
werden wir journalisten spüren es auch
wenn wir berichte machen und dann kommen
massenhaft troll einträge in den foren
die falsches behaupten und natürlich
haben sie auch die offizielle propaganda
die lügen verbreitet russia today aber
noch viel wirksamer ist im endeffekt die
ausstrahlung der russischen staatsmedien
über satellit was haben viele
russischstämmige in deutschland auch
konsumieren soviel zum thema propaganda
da ich habe es eben schon gesagt du bist
in odessa von wo auch die ersten
getreideexporte seit kriegsbeginn jetzt
wieder auf dem seeweg losgeschickt
werden sollen wie ist da der aktuelle
stand
der aktuelle stand ist dass der
raketenanschlag am hafen von odessa
anscheinend keine so großen schäden
hinterlassen hat dass der export von
accra gefährdet sei in der unmittelbaren
zeit wir haben jetzt noch keine genauen
angaben waren es losgehen kann es wurde
aber gesagt dass der hafen von
rhodos
der erste sei in dem ein schiff geladen
wird und den hafen verlässt der
infrastrukturminister hat ganz klar
formuliert dass ein weiterer
raketenangriff auf einen hafen das ende
des abkommen bedeuten würde und hier
werden alle vorbereitungen getroffen
dass endlich der der weizen das getreide
abtransportiert werden kann dass es
doppelt wichtig die silos müssen leer
werden in afrika brauchen viele menschen
diese
getreidemengen sonst drohen dorthin
hungersnöte
und es ist eine geld einnahmequelle für
die ukraine man rechnet wenn das alles
gelingt mit einer milliarde dollar pro
monat an einnahmen
möglicherweise könnte es in den nächsten
tagen schon losgehen soweit die
situation in odessa du bist natürlich
dann auch nicht weit entfernt von der
front im süden wie sieht es da aus
im süden laufen die vorbereitungen für
eine gegenoffensive vor allem die region
und die um gegend um die stadt kerstan
die russisch besetzt ist die soll jetzt
bald anlaufen es wurde vom
präsidentenpalast verkündet dass man
damit rechnet dass schon im september
ein erfolg möglich sei wenn alles
gelingt es wurden systematisch
munitionsdepots bombardiert mit auch
modernen schweren waffen die jetzt im
einsatz sind eine brücke wurde getroffen
das ist sehr wichtig weil person liegt
westlich des knie pro und das macht
diese gegend für die russische armee
relativ schwer mit nachschub zu
versorgen und auch eventuell zu halten
und dadurch dass die brücke beschädigt
ist kann natürlich dieser nachschub was
ähnlich die stärke der russen war in
diesem bisherigen krieg vor probleme
gestellt sein und lass uns noch zum
abschluss einmal kurz in den osten
schauen dort von dort werden anhaltende
kämpfe im donbass gemeldet wie es da die
lade
wir waren ja selbst bevor wir darüber
deshalb gekommen sind im don bosco den
haag f dort ist die lager massive
beschuss und die taktik der russen mit
der sie schon zwei städte eingenommen
hatten wie es wäre doch netz die wird
weiter fortgeführt massiver
artilleriebeschuss auf die ukrainische
front vor allem in richtung slovan und
langsames vorrücken und die ukrainische
soldaten müssen immer entscheiden wie
lange sie die stellung halten wie viele
opfer sie bereit sind für diese stellung
und irgendwann wenn ein teil der stadt
oder vielleicht sogar die gesamte stadt
richtig zerstört ist macht ja auch eine
verteidigung nicht mehr so wirklich viel
sinn dara hassanzadeh an dieser stelle
ganz lieben dank und bis bald und alles
gute die und deinem team schieße
ich auch
da hat es ja anfangs schon angesprochen
die russischen außer in diesem krieg
sind für alle die den krieg ablehnen ihr
sowieso nicht nachvollziehbar aber
darüber hinaus widersprechen sie sich
teilweise auch nina niebergall hat diese
verschiedenen aussagen weil
zusammengefasst
der russische außenminister lawrow auf
droht mit einem regime wechsel in kiew
damit dass die regierung von selen ski
gestürzt werden könnte aber wie
glaubhaft ist das spielen wir ein wenig
zurück zum 14 februar
2022 ist chance gibt es ihrer meinung
nach noch eine chance mit unseren
partnern eine einigung über wichtige
themen zu erzielen die uns sorgen
bereiten oder ist es nur ein versuch und
sind endlose verhandlungen zu ziehen es
kann schnell
als chef des außenministeriums muss ich
sagen dass es immer eine chance leben
währenddessen hat russland längst panzer
hunderttausende soldaten an der
ukrainischen grenze zusammengezogen
die spekulationen dass die russe speller
russischen manöver gestartet wurden um
die ukraine aus dem norden anzugreifen
um hier zu erobern all diese szenarien
sind völlig paranoid
etwa eine woche später marschierte
russland in die ukraine ein outfit
bombardiert die ersten kriegswochen
vergehen wir haben nicht vor das regime
in der ukraine zu wechseln so lawrow in
einem interview damals
der russische firma stockt es gibt hohe
verluste auf beiden seiten russland
formuliert ein erstes kriegsziel
bedingungslose priorität ist die
befreiung der johnen donetsk und lohans
knapp zwei monate später klingt auch das
wieder ganz anders vor wenigen tagen
sagte wolf wenn der westen immer mehr
waffen liefert werde russland seine
geografischen ambitionen in der ukraine
weiter ausdehnen
ja ich habe ja eben schon in einem
kommentar von dem user vorgelesen der
gefragt hat was kann man denn eigentlich
noch glauben über russische
kriegsrhetorik und propaganda wollen wir
jetzt sprechen und zwar mit dem
militärexperten oberst a d wolfgang
richter von der stiftung wissenschaft
und politik guten abend herr
richter warum hat live das jetzt gesagt
dass er die ukrainische regierung
stürzen will warum hat er das jetzt
gesagt und warum sagt dass überhaupt
jetzt zunächst einmal dass wir
festhalten dass wir aus moskau schon
sehr unterschiedliche vorstellungen über
die kriegsziele gehört haben jahrelang
haben wir über die nato erweiterung
diskutiert früher gab es dazu sogar auf
der träger über die rüstungskontrolle
die letzten vorschläge vom dezember
vertrags vorschläge haben ja das
widergespiegelt
und dann haben wir das seit dem letzten
jahr etwa auch seit dieser im sommer
seit dieser zeit wird man genau ein jahr
ist es her die vorstellungen von putin
gesehen dass es eben eine historische
die hatten die historische analyse
versucht auch der sagt die beiden völker
gehören zusammen früher gehört das zum
zahlreichen das wäre also letztlich dann
ein anderes motiv als das
sicherheitspolitische darin das ist ja
eher ein imperiales dass ich daher
überlegt und das dritte motiv war dann
eben etwas bescheidener nämlich der
schutz der bevölkerung
die aus russischer sicht pro russland
oder russland raffin ist im don was das
gilt sicher auch dann aus russischer
sicht für den süden wir haben also ganz
unterschiedliche vorstellungen was die
kriegsziele sind sie scheinen sich im
laufe der zeit auch mit dem verlauf der
militärischen ereignisse verändert zu
haben aber natürlich fragt man sich
warum sagt ja dass genau jetzt und warum
sagt der sg in kairo und ich glaube das
muss man eine ordnung denn man muss
nicht nach kairo fahren da man solches
kriegsziel zu verkünden sondern es ging
russland im grunde genommen darum die
internationale blockade die der westen
ausgerufen hat gegen russland zu
besprechen dazu nach der ausland zu
weisen er beginnt natürlich bei einem
afrikanischen staat der den
großen nahesteht oder der sowjetunion
journal stand gibt einbezieht das bezog
frühere sowjetische waffen jetzt immer
mehr russische waffen und vor allem in
ägypten der hauptempfänger des getreides
das event blockiert ist also es gibt
viele gründe warum man ausgerechnet in
kairo beginnt und dann von dort aus so
eine stellungnahme abgibt was aber auch
zu sagen ist in militärische lage gibt
es ja im grunde genommen gar nicht her
dass weit gesteckte maximal kriegsziel
denn de facto ist es ja so wie wir
gerade im letzten beitrag auch gehört
haben dass die fortschritte im don was
relativ langsam sind kleine schritte
lokale überlegenheit der artillerie aber
dann doch ein langsames durchbohren fast
schon millimeterweise während in carson
im westen die ukraine nun eine
gegenoffensive vorbereiten die
allerdings im moment auch nicht recht
vorankommt also ich sehe hier eher eine
balance der möglichkeiten und
wahrscheinlich wird am ende
entscheidend sein wer über die größere
ressourcen verfügt in einem solchen
materialschlacht hinein mir davon kann
luzerner schreibt dazu auf youtube
immerhin sind die russen jetzt mal
ehrlich hat ja lange genug gedauert herr
richter da sind sie wieder der richter
lassen sie uns aber dieses szenario
jetzt mal kurz durch reden weil
unabhängig von den kämpfen an der front
ist es ja so dass wenn es russland
gelingen würde ein attentat auf den
ukrainischen präsidenten zu verüben und
dieser das nicht überleben würde was
würde das mit der kampfmoral der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die ja
wirklich so beachtlich ist in den
letzten monaten was würde es mit denen
machen
zunächst mal sind wir natürlich hier im
bereich der spekulation
wir müssen festhalten dass ein versuch
ja schon im märz gemacht worden ist von
norden her tf1 daneben sozusagen im
handstreich ich habe das gefühl dass
hier die russische armee eigentlich
opfer selbst morattis des präsidenten
geworden dass dann wenn man glaubt dass
die ukraine keine homogenität aufweisen
keine nationale identität und lässt dich
die russischen truppen als befreier
begrüßen werden dann macht man natürlich
auch militärische fehler und bereitet
sich nicht taktisch und logistisch gut
vor man glaubt man im handstreich nach
kiew rhein fahren zu können und erlebt
dann ein weiterer und das ist genau dort
passiert hier was muss man sich mit
großen verlusten zurückziehen dieses
szenario können wir schon mal
vom tisch nehmen ja ich glaube auch
nicht dass das im moment eine
realistische alternative ist zu glauben
man kann ein solches szenario
wiederholen
gutachten karte darüber mag man
spekulieren aber ich glaube das ist eher
unwahrscheinlich
vor allem müssen wir sehen dass die
ukraine große sicherheitsmaßnahmen um
den präsidenten herum getroffen haben
ich glaube eher dass die russen darauf
anspielen dass sich die situation von
2014 wiederholen könnte wo noch große
teile gerade im süden und osten der
bevölkerung sich als russland auf ihn
gezeigt haben keine der ukrainischen
flotte damals vor allem sind
übergelaufen zur russischen armee hier
der schwarzmeerflotte und der widerstand
die verteidigung gute dann auch
freiwillige
das hat sich natürlich erheblich
geändert das hat offenbar russland nicht
so wahrgenommen
man nimmt hier die minderheit die ist
sicherlich noch gibt man sieht es ja
auch am donnerstag mit 35.000
armeeangehörigen die auf der anderen
seite stehen man nimmt diese
bürgerkriegssituation
in einer anderen weise war als wir das
tun dann verwechselte minderheit und
mehrheit offenbar und das führt zu
diesen fehleinschätzung das ändert aber
nichts an der tatsächliche militärischen
lage die ressourcen frage ist längst
nicht gelöst natürlich kann russland
auch auf ressourcen server greifen die
ukraine ist abhängig vom westlichen
lieferungen
lassen sie uns noch mal kurz bei diesem
thema psychologische kriegsführung
bleiben ihre kollegin margarete klein
hat da letzte woche bei uns im stream
bei zdf heute live darüber gesprochen
daher kurz rein was wir in bezug auf
westliche staaten zu erwarten haben ist
sicherlich zum herbst hinein eine viel
stärkere sogenannte psychologische
kriegsführung operation oder den versuch
durch propaganda und desinformation eben
die innenpolitische debatte zu drehen
dann für putin ist eine schwäche
westlicher staaten diejenigen dass die
dortigen politiker auf die öffentliche
meinung rücksicht nehmen müssen und
deswegen versucht man ganz gezielt die
öffentliche meinung zu beeinflussen
damit von dort aus druck auf die
führungen ausgeübt wird dass man sagt na
ja es hat eigentlich gar keinen sinn die
ukraine zu unterstützen ein schlechter
waffenstillstand sei besser als die
fortsetzung des krieges was aber
letztendlich nur russische gebiete und
russische gewinne konsolidieren würde
der richter ist eine solche ankündigung
die ukrainische regierung stürzen zu
wollen auch eine ganz klare botschaft an
den westen
also ich glaube dass wir im westen nicht
verfangen das ist der ehe eine drohung
entweder mit einem attentat was ich aber
jetzt wieder wahrscheinlich halte zumal
es ja keine innenpolitische auswirkungen
hätte denn es gibt genügend kräftige
ukraine die diesen krieg diese
verteidigen weiterführen werden aber ich
denke wenn es um eine solche hilfe wie
er sagt geht dann wird sich das
ukrainische volk von einer solchen
regierung befreit dann kann es nicht
eine militärische operation handeln und
hier sehe ich noch keine entsprechenden
erfolgsaussichten ich glaube dass im
moment auf allen seiten maximal ziele
formuliert werden und ich glaube keiner
tut gut daran im westen jetzt über so
etwas wie eine kapitulation frieden zu
reden natürlich ist das gar nicht mehr
gilt auf der anderen seite wird es aber
in frieden am ende auch nur geben wenn
man letztlich dann doch verhandelt aber
das heißt er dass alle von ihren maximal
ziehen abweichen müssen ein solcher
frieden kann ja nur unterhalb von
maximal zielen erfolgen wie das bisher
die historische erfahrung ist und das
darf weder kapitulation seien noch
überzogene forderungen einer total
ruiniert der russischen armee etwa oder
der russischen wirtschaft denn wir sehen
ja auf allen möglichen ebenen auf der
wirtschaft liegen dabei auf der
militärischen dass man auf allen seiten
versuchte solchen maximalforderungen
etwas entgegenzusetzen und das läuft er
dann auf eine materialschlacht hinaus
und er fragt man sich wer kann
eigentlich mehr ressourcen aufbringen
über der ressourcen entsprechen wir
gleich noch es gibt eine frage auf
youtube was die einschätzung ist ob der
krieg so lange laufen wird bis die ganze
ukraine eingenommen ist oder ob den
russen ein gewisser teil reichen wird
das ist eine frage an welche verstanden
wir schauen in die glaskugel hier sind
beim spekulieren am ende wird auch in
russland oder die russische führung
natürlich zu einem schluss kommen müssen
dann abwägt was denn noch tragbar ist
weitere hohe militärische verluste in
kauf zu nehmen oder an irgendeinem punkt
zu sagen das war es jetzt putin ist ja
frei einen sieg zu erklären wenn er es
für richtig hält oder wir ja
unterschiedlich innovative bereits
gehört hat das geht wenn ich mal an die
äußerungen von präsident selensky vom
märz anknüpfen da hat er drei vorschläge
gemacht erstens verzicht auf den
nato-beitritt zweiten sonderstatus für
den boom bust der zwischen den
präsidenten verhandelt wird und drittens
einen sonderstatus fällt die crème bia
der arbeit zunächst einmal für 15 jahre
verschoben wird so dass man das dann
noch mal neu beginnen kann ist dahin so
etwas wie eine de facto anerkennung der
russischen kontrolle nicht gehe also
nicht recht
das waren ja schon sehr weitreichende
vorschläge und sind alle seiten offenbar
von solchen vorschlägen abgeglichen
haben maximal ziele gesetzt ich glaube
realisten was bedeutet dass man
unterhalb der maximal ziele am ende zu
einem nüchternen ergebnis kommen muss
und das wird wahrscheinlich doch
irgendwo dort liegen wo sie lenski
bereits ende märz seine vorschläge
gemacht hat topolino hat noch eine frage
wird
staatsgebiet dann einfach russisch im
falle eines putsches gegen selensky
das glaube ich eher nicht denn wir haben
ja nicht nur eine figur die in der
ukraine den widerstand trägt sondern man
muss ja noch deutlich sehen dass selen
cigs vorschläge die ja schon sehr
weitreichend waren auch auf ihren
politischen widerstand gestoßen sind
weil das gefühl der nationalen identität
ist natürlich im laufe der acht jahre
seit der kreation erheblich
angestiegen die ukraine hatte noch nie
so eine identität oder nationale einheit
gehabt wie das jetzt der fall es nach
dem russland angegriffen hat wir können
sogar vielleicht zynisch feststellen
weil es so im gegensatz zu dem negativ
von putin ist putin hat dazu beigetragen
dass die identität der ukrainische
nationen nun werde deutlich angestiegen
ist dass es nicht nur den besten
betrifft wie das vielleicht historisch
oder traditionell war sondern jetzt bis
weit in den osten hinein reicht auch die
russischsprachige bevölkerung betrifft
und das heißt der widerstand wird nicht
nur an seelands gegeben es gibt genügend
führungsfiguren in der ukraine um das
weiter zu tragen ich behaupte sogar der
widerstandswillen würde auch dann nicht
brechen wenn kiew gekommen ist lassen
sie uns zum schluss noch kurz darüber
sprechen wie die ukraine zurzeit
militärisch gerüstet ist heute sind ja
die ersten drei flugabwehr panzer vom
typ gepard eingetroffen auf diese panzer
der bundeswehr hatte das land schon
lange gewartet und heute sind sie eben
angekommen zusammen mit 10 tausend
schuss munition
die
bundesregierung hatte ende april 30
ausgemusterte exemplare versprochen
diese mussten aber noch instand gesetzt
werden eigentlich sollten sie bis mitte
juli schon da sein insgesamt 15 herr
richter inwiefern verbessert dass nun
die militärische situation für das
ukrainische militär
ja da muss man zunächst einmal die
westlichen waffenlieferungen im kontext
sehen werden wir sehen was die nato
staaten geliefert haben also allen voran
natürlich erstmal polen mit 240 t 72
panzern auch viele andere staaten um die
amerikaner mit sehr vielen haupt prinzen
auch deutschland hat sich gemeinsam mit
holland hier eingeleitet mit dem
modernen panzer hat jetzt 2000
frankreich und großbritannien da liegen
etwa auf der gleichen ebene und wenn man
das alles zusammenfasst dann kommen wir
auf schwere waffen die in die hunderte
gehen also wir sind bei etwa 250
westlichen h putzen dazu kommen eine
ganze reihe von hopkins in östlicher
bauart die kampfpanzer habe ich genannt
und in diesen rahmen reizt dich jetzt
ein was wir jetzt sehen diese gepard
lieferungen das ist ja wunderbar erste
tranche der ersten szene von 15 weitere
fünf sensoren folgen und der gepard als
solcher hat natürlich eine hohe
feuerkraft er ist eigentlich ein fleck
panzer also eine flugabwehr panzer der
in der lage ist die trockene in der
bewegung gegen luftangriffe aus dem
niedrigen höhen zu schützen entsprechend
dagegen niedrig fliegender flugzeuge gab
bomber und kampfhubschrauber er hat aber
auch eine feuerkraft gegen bodenziele
und die ist ganz erheblich das heißt er
wird schon dazu beitragen dass die
feuerkraft erheblich wenn er verstärkt
wird aber man muss das in diesem kontext
einbauen denn die zahl als solche ist ja
zunächst einmal geringer
wird für sich natürlich jetzt kein game
changer sein wie man das überhaupt nicht
bei einzelnen waffensystem sagen kann
das ist die das ist die taktischen
regeln ganz dreht wenn am ende kommt es
darauf an wie man seine waffen
vernünftig aufeinander abgestimmt
einsetzen dass man im
westentaschenformat
das haben sie jetzt gut eingeordnet denn
für ricoh hat uns auf youtube
geschrieben das ist doch lächerlich
wenig wie sie sagen im
gesamtzusammenhang sieht das dann
natürlich etwas anders ausschauen wir
noch mal auf die deutschen
waffenlieferungen es gibt ja probleme
mit dem sogenannten ringtausch denn
ursprünglich war geplant das östliche
nato partner wie polen und tschechien
ältere panzer sowjetischer bauart in die
ukraine liefern das ist zwei geschehen
nur hat deutschland diese partnerländer
dafür noch nicht wie sehr vereinbart war
mit moderneren leopard panzern
ausgestattet und jetzt werden die
stimmen in der bundesregierung laut
solche panzer eben nicht über umwege
sondern direkt an die ukraine zu liefern
was würden sie sagen ringtausch oder
direktlieferung er zu beginn des krieges
allerdings immer das angesagte weil es
einfach schneller geht weil man für
einen ringtausch die gleichen systeme
verwenden kann die man direkt in die
ukraine schickt die dort im einsatz sind
also diese t-72 beispielsweise dafür
braucht man nicht ausbilden und hat die
munition und auch keine software kette
aufbauen ich kann man übernehmen und
damit kämpfen das wird aber jetzt ein
wenig anders ende kommen denn diese
waffen ströme sind erschöpft und auch
die verluste der ukraine nehmen zu und
es wird man daran gehen irgendwann mal
auch auf westliches gerät umzuschalten
das ist bei den hobbits im geschehen die
artillerie stellt im moment um auf
westliches systeme was die kampfpanzer
betrifft betrifft das hat aber auch eine
politische dimension bevor ich mal auf
das technische komme denn bisher hat
noch kein staat auch die usa nicht
kampfpanzer westlicher bauart in die
ukraine geliefert wenn dann wäre das
kein alleingang deutschlands das würde
man dann noch zusammen und mit den usa
großbritannien und frankreich
wie sehr hat keiner das geliefert ich
sage nicht dass das eine rote linie
überschritten werden kann aber es macht
ja schon ein unterschied ob ein
kampfpanzer der eben eine typisch
deutsche signatur hat russische truppen
über die grenzen treibt
und dann sind wir allein gabe oder ob es
jetzt um eine patientin konstatiert der
westliche aktion geht also das ist nun
mal die politische seite die technische
seite jetzt aber eine andere die
bundeswehr verfügt nicht über
ausreichend kampfpanzer in den aktiven
verbänden es gibt zu viele kampf
panzerbataillone die letztlich nur über
die hälfte ihres soll bestands dafür die
bundeswehr hat aber die verpflichtung
jetzt die bündnisverteidigung
vorzubereiten und schrittweise eine bis
2025 eine panzerdivision auf zustand um
die ostflanke der nato zu schützen das
ist eine verpflichtung die in madrid
getroffen worden ist denn man sich nicht
entziehen kann dafür gibt es auch nicht
nur die allgemeine erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushalts sondern auch
dieses sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
und das muss möglichst schnell jetzt
passieren dass die truppe die ja nicht
voll ausgestattet ist dann auch voll
ausgestattet wird und es geht nicht
anders geht dann am ende auch munition
ich glaube das ist sogar noch die uhr
ist der größte engpass denn die
westliche industrie vor allem die
deutsche industrie ist ja auch eine
kriegsproduktion im moment nicht
eingestellt ich sehe damit noch keinen
umsteuern auf kriegsproduktion aber ich
sehe das ist ein dilemma gibt nämlich
die eigene verteidigung zu stärken was
ja eine verpflichtung ist der nato und
der bundesregierung und zum anderen aus
den depots waffensysteme älterer bauart
herauszuholen die natürliche ressourcen
verschlingen bis sie dann einsatzbereit
gemacht werden und dafür ersatzteile zu
finden und die munition et cetera und
noch auszubilden also das muss schon
gegeneinander abgewogen werden und
einfach zum regal zu gehen und die dinge
abzuholen das wäre dann doch zu einfach
jetzt noch eine meinung reingekommen von
anna so renner auf youtube
da würde ich gerne wissen wie ihre
antwort ist russland droht übrigens
nicht mit einem regime change in kiew es
bietet lediglich seine unterstützung an
das ist etwas ganz anderes was wenn sie
an antworten
na ja das ist die lektion von darauf
gewesen das ist mir auch aufgefallen
dass er sagt wir helfen den ukrainern
dabei aber das sind natürlich
formulierungen die das ganze vielleicht
etwas abfedern sollen aber an der essenz
der aussage glaube ich ist ja nichts
zurück nicht zu rütteln das war nämlich
schon glaubt auf der ebenfalls lawrow
hat das so ausgeprägt dass man in der
lage wäre die virus die ukrainische
opposition so zu stärken dass sie zu
einem solchen putscht wenn man das denn
so lernen wir in der lage ist ohne dass
russische truppen beim vorstoss müssten
das sehe ich als totale illusion an
obwohl ich nicht bestreitet dass das
natürlich russland affine
bevölkerungsteile gibt auf der krim
rentner was vielleicht noch im süden wo
die ukraine ja selber darum ringen um
festzustellen wie kann es zu einer
solchen kooperation kommen dass im süden
gebiete eingenommen werden von
russischen truppen ohne großen
widerstand ohne dass brücken gesprengt
werden übrigens dafür dass nicht der spd
verantwortlich für wolken sprengungen
ist die armee verantwortlich und noch
eine letzte frage für heute von jens
heppner auf youtube herr richter müssen
wir wirklich zu sehen wenn russland das
durchzieht
ich vermute er meint wenn russland die
ukraine völlig unter kontrolle nehmen
will
nun zu sehen das kann man ja nichts
sagen also wenn sie sich anschauen was
westliche regierungschefs miteinander
vereinbart haben dann kann man sagen das
ist ja eine doppelstrategie gibt und
zwar einerseits die militärische hilfe
und finanzielle und wirtschaftliche
hilfe für die ukraine
auf der anderen seite aber auch den
versuch russland so zu isolieren dass
die russische wirtschaft in die knie
geht der zweite teil der strategie
inhaltlich jetzt schon für gescheitert
offen gesagt weil es gelingt nicht den
globalen süden davon zu überzeugen dass
die parteien nehmen sollen in einem
neuen ost west konflikt der aus sicht
des globalen südens in erster linie im
konflikt zwischen nördlichem staaten ist
und das heißt vor allen dingen ein
konflikt zwischen ehemaligen
kolonialmächten das heißt hier hat man
einen ganz anderen blick auf die dinge
und selbst staaten die sich selbst als
demokratisch sehen wir haben es beim
g7-gipfel erlebt werden diese diese
block konfrontation nicht wollen wir
nicht daran teilnehmen das ist noch die
frage ob das langfristig im interesse
der internationalen ausbau ist wenn man
die un dann so spaltet ich glaube eher
dass es darum gehen muss die ukraine zu
befähigen ein widerstand zu leistende
ihre verhandlungsposition verbessern so
dass sie am ende ihre souveränität
wahren können aber der dritte aspekt
einer strategie die habe ich bisher
vermisst es muss auch den versuch geben
vernünftige verhandlungslösung haben
vorzuschlagen die etwa dort liegen
könnten das talent scouts vorschlag ja
schon im märz lag hier glaube ich kann
man noch mehr tun
auch diese möglichkeit einer
diplomatischen lösung immer wieder ins
auge zu fassen setzen sie heute
vielleicht nicht machbar ist aber
erschöpfungszustand zunimmt dann glaube
ich dann wird es darauf hinauslaufen
herr richter ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für ihre einschätzung und fürs
geduldige fragen beantworten machen sie
es gut danke für alles gute nach belegen
dankeschön und auch euch vielen dank für
eure fragen und eure meinungen ich hoffe
wir sehen uns bald wieder bis teppich